Your old body wash is okay, but there's one problem:...
...it doesn't smell like Sour Patch Kids.
Well, guess what?
Now it can.
Introducing Shower Patch Kids Body Wash.
Available in four classic scents.
The only body wash that takes your favorite candy out of your mouth...
...and rubs it all over your body.
First the sour invigorates, then the sweet alleviates.
And the shimmering sugar crystals exfoliate,...
...making you feel like a new person with all the same problems.
And just like your bite-sized buddies, it's 100 percent edible.
So you can satisfy your sweet tooth while you scrub.
First you're sour, then you're sweet, then you're irresistible.
Put a little sour in your shower with new Shower Patch Kids 2-in-1 Body Wash.
Sour.
Sweet.
Clean.